dans ce ring de boxe de belfastes depuis
jillistes protestants et catholiques
s'affrontent les couples pleuvent on
esquive on frappe encore et le sang qui
colle ici n'a rien à voir avec les
violences communautaires qui ont déchiré
le pays pendant 30 ans
je suis trop jeune pour avoir souvenir
de ces violences 17 entraîneuse mais
nous souffrons d'un traumatisme
intergénérationnel ajoutait les choses
ont changé mais pas encore assez
épreuve ces murs et rigides à la fin des
années 60 pour séparer les communautés
catholiques et protestantes de belles
fastes le gouvernement Nord irlandais
avait promis de les détruire mais ils
sont encore debout longue frontières de
13 km qui continue de diviser la ville
la chute du mur comme à Berlin dit ce
professeur mais ce n'est jamais arrivé
ouais si aujourd'hui les deux
communautés arrivent à cohabiter au
centre-ville il reste des quartiers où
elles vivent encore totalement séparés
ce sont justement si divisions que
souhaitaient facile l'école maternelle
Bangor une des rares économiques de
l'Irlande du Nord
j'ai toujours espoir que nous devenions
une société meilleure de la directrice
de l'école et le plus tôt nous abordons
les différences avec les enfants le plus
vite cela pourrait arriver
[Musique]
cette lacune
salle de boxe devient ainsi l'endroit où
ces jeunes adultes de demain peuvent se
rencontrer et apprendre à se connaître
loin des étiquettes confessionnelles ici
lise Villeneuve Radio-Canada MONT